skin erasers
yeah all right have fun mentor from the
guy said what's that is the boss's
mentor he was he was a guy that his mind
mentoring was yours he was scarfo's he
was scoffs no he hated Chicago please
don't and I know you were told this that
people you had in here are making a
story yet that's why you leonetti makes
up stories Oh Phil Leonetti
yes he makes up story yes he's not to
kill he's supposed to be Phil Leonetti
makes up stories
yes I mean it's been I wouldn't say that
you would have known that skinny razor
was known as a guy that skinny razor was
the most feared man in the United States
but then he wouldn't talk to them people
went talk to fooling lens of you or
Nicky Scarfo he became when he got 45
years he became a witness the only time
I'd be paying it became a witness was at
the end when I took him to a million
being right they made a Morse where you
gotta take care of my family cuz I'm
gonna say they needed help in the city
they were trying I was someone to put
that group together nobody else
I said well you got to promise me one
thing on our blood something happens to
me well I get killed
I go to jail you go and bring your
envelope every Monday I mean every month
excuse me and bring it over to my wife
good you know what happened
another time not a dime that's what they
are that's why I'm here a little bit
what's Joe we got to do a leonetti and
scarf for though Joe we should kill
Bashar was they were together as
brothers one time me ladies not Scarfo
is a sick man he was born sick he's
gonna dissect and Leonetti
he wanted leonetti's Ribisi you're gonna
you got the story first and you believed
it
he wanted leonetta to be honored and
wrote about in the paper like other
people that's what he wanted he wanted
an under to be like he wanted him to be
like salvie testa salvie testa was the
purest young killer but everybody says
that so so what you say no what you're
saying right there is to challenge you a
little bit no why would you challenge me
no no to challenge you on that a little
bit Leonetti also believes salvie testa
was a great guy well because she's
telling you you're listening to him when
you're saying the same thing no I'm not
i said sally was Leonelli cell phonee no
no Leonetti said sally is also great guy
Oh Diane you believe that he he wanted
to kill him he was told to kill him when
he had a chance because he reported to
skarphol Nicky Scarfo hated almond kids
from downtown course everyone knows that
my boy do you say everyone that you're
telling me something about no no
everyone knows that no didn't listen we
went when smart okay you tell me when
skarphol passed away three years ago not
a lot of people showed up to his funeral
you know nothing that there was not a
lot of here I know he was hated he hated
me yeah he would curse Scott because I a
strange little Bruno many years before
that I'm gonna go kill Nicky he's gonna
cause us problems with Atlantic City you
said that to Angelo Buono they were
gonna call kill Nicky I'm not gonna
repeat that why should I repeat you
didn't hear me I said it and you know
what he said to me don't you dare he's
as his uncle's came over than when the
boat would me the war that we had with
the Americanized Angeles because when
they came off the boat they called him
zips and they start a fight nonsense the
numbers been there everything every
little gambling house that's what
happened Nicky Scarfo was scum
[Music]
you
[Music]